hey what's poppin insecure cardi B I'm
going undercover on the internet and
this is actually me okay let's see what
is this about let me answer these
questions Twitter cardi B doesn't act
human she's like some alien from the
future here to show us how it's going to
be I'm actually very human like a lot of
people think that these celebrity is I
don't have feelings and everything I'm a
very emotional person
I pretty much won the same [ __ ] you want
[ __ ] yo I'm cardi B what's your
favorite song to strip to back in the
day I used to like to dance to like
house music I used to like dance like
James really loosely really sensual that
was one of the songs I used to love to
dance so the cardi B join me goes or
something they seem like a two-for-one
these days buy one get one free what the
hell why not if I'm gonna be around them
for a long time why would they want to
have a bum [ __ ] around them there's not
doing [ __ ] why not be a rich successful
family like oh my god your boyfriend
friends suck they party talk [ __ ] about
you and encourage him to [ __ ] get his
dick sucked by other [ __ ] nah man
strength they be trying to told me to
deliver when it comes to me like I don't
know I'm sorry I don't know if that's a
problem yeah I find a problem with
everything you - yeah why with those
weird sounds I'm just a comedian at
heart like I have like a hundred people
working in my like a mess on my brain I
always been like this in school
everything it just makes me feel good
like I don't know why I do it my head
functions really differently I wish
somebody could like go inside my ear go
to my brain and find out what's going on
over there because not only
ready it's actually me nah that ass this
is really me try to be interview on The
Tonight Show is that her real
personality or is all night a lot of
people was gonna question my background
I like people wanna question my gangster
a lot of people want to question
everything and his like I hate when
people do that but then it kind of makes
me happy because like so many people
know me and knew me and everybody could
always tell you that this is what I've
been doing before Fame just wad baby for
fame there's the type of [ __ ] I was
saying before Fame why am i gonna add
four legs posted Wikipedia during her
teenage years cardi B was employed at a
supermarket in lower Manhattan which was
the last job that she had before turning
to stripping at the age of 19 that's
true I used to work in this supermarket
called
Amish market I work about there for six
months I had to drop out of school
because I have responsibilities and you
know they fired me from there so
stripping I don't recommend it to
everybody because there's some bad sway
but it helped me a lot I got my first
apartment
it got me my first few thousands I met a
lot of people there's pros and cons I
started recommend the fight for people
because some people are not built for it
you don't say I submitted it more
Twitter its car to be gonna drop an
album or what yes I am gonna drop our
album and you're gonna love it
I just learned today that cardi B real
name is Belle Calise mens are I said
that [ __ ] out loud and my furniture
started floating does my name is Onika
a spell bocalee so men's or does it I
don't know I guess whatever I like my
name is weird and is unique and my dad
made it up so that's cool ever notice
how long cardi beat song is yeah
I have a very long tongue I feel like I
can't keep it inside my mouth for too
long I feel like a [ __ ] loser but I
love my tongue it works wonders quota
boom it's actually me do you think cardi
B will be the next queen of rap that's
not something that I care much about
like I just want to make music and be
rich in order to be the queen of rap
that you have to live up to a certain
expectation you have to have like a
certain expectation of lyrics and stuff
like that as I had to music that make me
feel happy there I that I want to bounce
to that I like and love so I really
don't care about stuff like that
what does cardi be like in her average
day to day life
most likely somebody is waking me up I'm
gonna sell you gotta do a photo shoot I
mean like you gotta do an interview I'm
always on go go go time or if I'm not
gonna go go go time I'm in sleep sleep
sleep mood
there's cardi B do cardio no the most
workout I ever did was when I used to
strip you know I used to climb poles and
shake my ass I think that I I never I
never had to do before I need so because
you know I'm getting older I'm 25 my
woman body's starting to come out yeah
okay well I hope you learned some things
about me goodbye
cuz I gotta go I'm hungry and I got a
gap crew all right
I don't what is this okay help me